Our story doesn't begin in the Lands Between;
it begins in the cosmos, far away with an
Outer God called "The Greater Will".
There are..a lot of Outer Gods mentioned in
Elden Ring (Note: At least 6, maybe more).
You can think of these kind of like the Great
Ones of Bloodborne - distant beings..all powerful..and
quite unknowable, by design.
Many of these Outer Gods want to make their
presence felt in the world..The Greater Will
maybe most of all.
To this end, it sent a golden star hurtling
towards the Lands Between.
The Elden Stars incantation tells us that
this golden star was bearing a beast.
An Elden Beast.
The Elden Remembrance calls it a "vassal beast
of the Greater Will".
If you didn't know, a "vassal" is someone
who holds land on behalf of their overlord.
Obviously this is fitting in this case, because
the Elden Beast was an extension of the Greater
Will and a "living incarnation of the concept
of order" in the Lands Between.
As such, this beast would later become ... the
Elden Ring (Elden Remembrance).
The Elden Ring itself is made up of runes
of power.
Some Great, some small, that together represent
a sort of logic for the world to follow (inferred
by what follows).
Thus, the Elden Ring represents order.
The true nature of this order is a subject
of constant debate and research undergone
by fundamentalists..but two of the key fundamentals
are the laws of causality and regression.
You can think of the Law of Causality as cause
and effect, where actions have consequences
and those consequences are new causes that
"branch" out into infinity.
These are the relationships between things.
Then there's the Law of Regression, that states
that all things eternally yearn to converge,
and return to their roots.
Fittingly then, the Elden Ring is housed within
the Erdtree, which towers over the Lands Between.
But it's very important to stress that life
in the Lands Between did not begin WITH the
Erdtree, the Elden Ring, or the Elden Beast.
No..the Lands Between were occupied well before
the Greater Will came.
There were other beings here (Deathbird descriptions,
Giant Descriptions)..there were other factions
here (carians, giants)..there were other Gods
here (One-Eyed Shield, Twinbird Kite Shield).
There was even..another Great Tree here, before
the Erdtree.
And this is where a huge twist regarding the
Erdtree comes in.
So, there are incantations in the game called
"Aspects of the Crucible".
According to their descriptions, these are
"manifestations of the Erdtree's primal vital
energies", and I quote - they are "an aspect
of the primordial crucible, where all life
was once blended together".
But how could ALL life be blended together
in the Erdtree, if the Erdtree appeared AFTER
life existed?
Well, there can only be one answer, right?
That the Erdtree is a parasite and took over
a tree that existed here before (Crucible
Tree Helm).
This tree was called..the Great Tree.
Root resin is secreted from the roots of the
great tree, and reads: "The roots of the Greattree
were once linked to those of the Erdtree."
(Theory: This connection might have been severed
due to deathroot)
So the Great Tree was a crucible of life itself,
and must have been a very powerful primordial
force for the Greater Will to commandeer.
It might even be the reason the Lands Between
is important to the Greater Will in the first
place.
It also explains why spells and enemies (see:
omen, misbegotten, crucible knights) related
to the Great Tree's crucible would eventually
be looked down upon.
For example, the Knot Talisman is fashioned
from a knotted vestige of the crucible, and
it "was considered a signifier of the divine
in ancient times, but is now increasingly
disdained as an impurity as civilization has
advanced."
Enemies related to the Great Tree's crucible
are the Omen ... the Misbegotten ... and the
Crucible Knights.
All of them would become shunned, enslaved,
or imprisoned.
Those who speak for the Erdtree ... don't
want you to know its roots, so to speak.
According to the spell "Protection of the
Erdtree", "In the beginning, everything was
in opposition to the Erdtree, but through
countless victories in war, it became the
embodiment of Order".
In Marika's own words: The Erdtree governs
all.
The choice is thine.
Become one with the Order.
Or divest thyself of it.
To wallow at the fringes; a powerless upstart.
To enforce order, the Greater Will required
loyal agents in the Lands Between.
To this end, the Two Fingers are its envoys
(Enia dialogue).
The Two Fingers Heirloom reads: Of course,
fingers cannot speak, yet these are eloquent.
Persistently they wriggle, spelling out mysteries
in the air.
Thus did we gain the words.
The words of our faith".
These "words" are interpreted by the Finger
Readers.
These are the undying (Talisman Pouch) old
crones found throughout the lands between,
who pass down the wisdom of the Two Fingers.
Or at least, they used to.
// who tell you random bullshit that makes
no sense and take up precious NPC markers
on your map
Your fingers..please, I can read them.
Most of them appear to have lost their purpose,
and are desperate to read your fingers since
their Two Fingers..are likely dead.
And yes, of course - there are multiple sets
of Two Fingers.
You would have found their corpses on the
tops of the Divine Towers.
Atop these towers, you loot the fingers in
order to activate the true power of a Great
Rune.
Specifically, you are giving "benediction"
back to your Great Rune (Unactivated Great
Rune description).
You're taking a blessing back from the dead
Two Fingers, essentially.
This is just one of many blessings that the
Two Fingers can bestow (Shadows, Eternal Life
to the Finger Readers)..and my point is - the
Two Fingers clearly have more than just influence.
They have real power.
(NOTE: This is further evidenced during Ranni's
questline, who goes to great lengths to slay
her own pair of fingers.)
The Greater Will needs these powerful envoys
and agents because while it's obviously incredibly
powerful, it does seem limited by a few things.
First, is space.
The Greater Will didn't come to the Lands
Between itself - it sent an Elden Beast to
do its bidding instead.
Second, is time.
There is a moment, later in the game, where
your pair of Two Fingers go still, forced
to consult the Greater Will for guidance.
"When they are finished, the Fingers will
again offer their guidance.
But thousands, if not tens of thousands, of
moons must first pass.
No matter for me.
But you?
How will you ever manage the wait..."
So the Greater Will needs a physical manifestation
of order..it needs envoys to convey its will..but
what it also needs.. is a god.
---
Introducing..Marika, the Eternal.
Most of the story of Elden Ring relates to
Marika in some way - she's essentially the
equivalent of Gwyn, from Dark Souls.
Except, unlike Gwyn, Marika didn't just crawl
out of the dark and find power..to an extent,
it seems like she earned it.
We don't know much about her origins, except
that she is of the "Numen" race, which is
actually an origin you can choose in the character
selection screen.
"Numen come from outside of the Lands Between,
and are supposed descendants of denizens of
another world.
Long-lived, but seldom born".
At some point, Marika was chosen as an Empyrean.
What is an empyrean?
An empyrean is a being "chosen by the fingers"
(Black Flame Ritual Incantation and Ranni
Dialogue) as a candidate for godhood (Ranni
dialogue).
As an empyrean, Marika received the aid of
a Shadow, to do her bidding.
So what is a Shadow?
- well, it's a wolf, shadowbound to its empyrean
by the Two Fingers (Iji Dialogue, Raging Wolf
Set).
Lunar Princess Ranni is another example of
an empyrean with a shadowbound beast.
These creatures are the empyrean's very own
shadow - completely loyal to their needs,
and by definition, incapable of treachery.
Marika's shadow was a beast called Maliketh.
Every empyrean uses their shadow in different
ways, but "Marika's sole need of her shadow
was a vessel to lock away Destined Death"
(Remembrance of the Black Blade).
So..what is Destined Death?
Well according to Enia - it's the Rune of
Death.
The Rune of Death goes by two names; the other
is Destined Death.
We mentioned earlier that the Elden Ring is
made up of runes - and at some point - maybe
when she was chosen as god, Marika plucked
the Rune of Death from the Elden Ring (Enia
Dialogue).
She gave the Rune of Death to Maliketh, her
totally loyal shadow - who bore a Black Blade
imbued with this rune (Maliketh's Armour).
Kind of genius, really.
In a single act, she removed the concept of
death from the Lands Between..while also commanding
total control of death through her shadow,
who could deliver it at her whim.
Now some of you might be asking - if death
is removed from the Lands Between, how come
I can kill this dog?
First off, shame on you.
Second - from a lore point of view, that dog
isn't really dead..it's simply in the process
of its spirit..or its soul ( D dialogue),
returning to the erdtree.
Catacomb dungeons are specifically constructed
near the roots of the Greattree for this reason,
so that the Erdtree can reabsorb their ashes
back into it (Root Resin).
This process replaced the concept of a death
you were "destined" to have.
But this random spirit outside a catacomb
dungeon says it best.
A proper death means returning to the Erdtree.
Have patience.
Until the time comes...and the roots call
to you.
As another example - when you kill a major
boss, you receive a "remembrance" of them.
These are spirits (Godfrey apparition fight),
"hewn into the Erdtree".
In this way, thanks to the Erdtree's grace..their
spirits are immortalised..
This new form of death also explains what's
happening when you summon spirits from ash.
Tis a bell for calling forth spirits.
Summon them with it, from ash unreturned to
the Erdtree.
However, some spirits never return to the
Erdtree, and rise within death as corpses
or skeletons instead.
(NOTE: This is partly because of Deathroot,
which we will address in another video)
Unthinkable.
Our hallowed resting place is violated.
To refuse the Erdtree's call to return, to
live within Death...
Sickening.
---
So this was the new order.
The Golden Order.
And it's important to stress that it was in
THIS moment - when the Rune of Death was removed..when
Destined Death was taken - THIS is when Order..
became the Golden Order.
The forbidden shadow plucked from the Golden
Order upon its creation.
Specifically, this was Marika's Golden Order.
So not only did she become a god and a vessel
for the Elden Ring (Enia dialogue)..she became
renowned as "Marika the Eternal" for her removal
of Destined Death.
However..Marika had more than just death to
conquer.
She had wars to fight, as the world was occupied
by many forces that could threaten her Golden
Order.
There was war with the Storm Lord, who likely
ruled over Stormveil..
There was a war with the giants, who were
masters of a flame that could burn the Erdtree..
There was a war with the Ancient Dragons,
who incidentally had stones that could twist
time, and thus slay a god..
And finally, there was war brewing with the
Carian Royalty, who had previously "obeyed
laws which contravened the Golden Order" (Corhyn
dialogue).
Thus, similar to how the Greater Will needed
an empyrean to enforce its will..Marika needed
someone to wage war.
So, there was to be a husband.
A consort.
An Elden Lord.
The man chosen was Hoarah Loux - a ferocious
warrior (Godfrey Icon) who became known as
the Lord of the Battlefield (Elden Lord Armor).
His crown was "warranted with strength" (Axe
of Godfrey), and while it was for this strength
that Marika married him - he was also required
to take a "vow to conduct himself as a lord"
(Axe of Godfrey).
To suppress the ceaseless lust for battle
that raged within, Hoarah Loux took the Beast
Regent Serosh upon his back.
You'll notice this is yet another example
of a beast being given for the purpose of
serving Order.
Thus, in this moment, he went from being Hoarah
Loux, warrior - to Godfrey..the First Elden
Lord (source: His reversion in the boss cutscene),
consort to Queen Marika, and a certified demi-god
(source: Godrick's Great Rune).
Godfrey and Marika had..at least three demi-god
children together.
There was Godwyn the Golden, who you saw being
killed in the opening trailer, and then there
were the reviled Omen twins: Morgott, who
guards the Erdtree..and Mohg, who became Lord
of Blood.
You might think Godrick was another demi-god
child - but he was not.
Instead, he was probably descended from Godwyn.
Godrick the Grafted was but a distant relation.
The runt of the litter, his divine blood sorely
diluted.
Anwyay, we'll talk about these demi-gods more
in detail in another video, so subscribe for
that - but for now, just know that Godfrey
and his offspring were the first demi-gods
(Godrick's Great Rune")...henceforth known
as the Golden Lineage.
Godfrey led the 16 (Crucible Axe Set) Crucible
Knights into battle, who were named so for
they fought with the primordial powers of
the Erdtree - their incantations were aspects
of its crucible, and they (likely) fought
Giants, Dragons, Storm Lords and more - to
usher in their age - the Age of the Erdtree.
Hark, brave warriors.
Hark, my lord Godfrey.
We commend your deeds.
Guidance hath delivered ye through each ordeal,
to the place ye stand.
Put the Giants to the sword, and confine the
flame atop the mount.
Let a new epoch begin.
An epoch glistening with life.
Brandish the Elden Ring, for the Age of the
Erdtree!
The Erdtree would go on to largely be seen
as a blessing for all those in the Lands Between
- especially those close to it in Llendell,
the Capital City of the Erdtree.
The tree bestowed blessings, for example - the
tears that dripped from its branches like
jewels (tear descriptions).
It loomed overhead as a constant reminder
of order, and its roots reached far and wide,
relieving many of the burden of death (roots
in the catacombs).
In fact, Erdtree Burial was one of the highest
honours a hero could receive (assorted spirit
ash descriptions).
---
One by one, the previous factions of the world
fell.
Stormveil was conquered, and the Storm Lord
was defeated.
The giants were put to the sword (Marika Dialogue),
and their Fell God was killed by Marika herself.
The Ancient Dragons broke down the walls of
Lleyndell, but met fierce retaliation (Elden
Lord Armor)..
However..
I think the House of the Erdtree encountered
the most trouble against the land to their
southwest.
Liurnia.
Here, the House of the Moon repelled their
offensives time and time again - for there
was not one, but two wars over this territory..and
in these, there was no victory for the golden,
nor for the moon.
(Sword Gravestone Lore x2).
Now I suspect..it was because of the lobsters.
These damn things can snipe you from like
a mile away Miyazaki come on this is BULLSH-
Actually, it was probably because of the Carian
Knights, who, according to their weapons,
were able to wield sorcerous battle skills,
and "despite numbering fewer than twenty,
this power made them a match for even the
champions of gold, in battle (Carian Knight's
Sword)."
Yes, glintstone pebble is that powerful.
These enchanted knights were anointed by the
Lunar Queen, a young astrologer (Stargazer
Heirloom) who went on to establish the House
of Caria as royalty in this land.
With her bewitching lunar magic, she won over
the Academy of Raya Lucaria where glintstone
sorcery was studied, and - united - the Carian
Royal Family and the learned sorcerers of
Raya Lucaria defended their home from the
golden aggressors.
At the head of the great golden host, was
Radagon.
Lord Radagon was a great champion, possessed
of flowing red locks.
He came to these lands at the head of a great
golden host, when he met Lady Rennala in battle.
These two champions clashed, fell in love,
and joined their houses.
Radagon once cleansed himself with celestial
dew,
repented his territorial aggressions, and
swore his love to Rennala.
The Order of the Erdtree and the fate of the
moon were conjoined, and all the wounds of
war forgiven.
You might think it strange that the Greater
Will would permit this union - but it's not
too odd, all things considered.
As with most From Software games, sorcery
and faith are two sides of the same coin - and
both of these powers stem from the cosmos.
In the past, they obeyed laws which contravened
the Golden Order, or so I'm told.
Fascinating, isn't it?
That the Golden Order was pliable enough to
absorb practices that contradicted itself
in the past.
Radagon and Rennala were known to have had
three children together.
Lunar Princess Ranni, who inherited her mother's
propensity for Lunar magic (Ranni's Dark Moon).
Radahn, who took after his father Radagon,
and would go on to master gravitational magic...and
Rykard..who pioneered new hex sorceries, and
would go on to feed himself to a great serpent.
(remembrance of the blasphemous)
---
It follows that at some point after all of
this, Marika began to harbour doubts.
Doubts about the Golden Order she had had
a hand in creating.
I declare mine intent, to search the depths
of the Golden Order.
Through understanding of the proper way, our
faith, our grace, is increased.
Those blissful early days of blind belief
are long past.
My comrades; why must ye falter?
It's at this point that we should talk about
Marika's motivations.
Her character.
This is surely going to be a point of debate
in the coming years, but for now..my working
theory is that she wanted to discover the
truth behind Order and the Greater Will.
That she believed bonds had to be broken,
so that they could be better understood.
That there was great meaning to be found..
in hardship.
Queen Marika has high hopes for us.
That we continue to struggle.
Unto eternity.
For Lord Godfrey, his struggle ended at the
end of his campaigns.
According to his armour - "He led the War
against the Giants.
Faced the Storm Lord, alone.
And then, there came a moment.
When his last worthy enemy fell.
And it was then, as the story is told, that
the hue of Lord Godfrey's eyes faded."
In truth, he was robbed of his grace (Remembrance
of Hoarah Loux).
Then Marika sent him away.
My Lord, and thy warriors.
I divest each of thee of thy grace.
With thine eyes dimmed, ye will be driven
from the Lands Between.
Ye will wage war in a land afar, where ye
will live, and die.
This became known as the Long March of the
Tarnished.
But Queen Marika had a plan.
That Lord Godfrey and their tarnished descendants
would one day return stronger, having struggled
outside of grace.
Then, after thy death, I will give back what
I once claimed.
Return to the Lands Between, wage war, and
brandish the Elden Ring.
Grow strong in the face of death.
Warriors of my lord.
Lord Godfrey.
---
Soon after, she found a new husband.
Either that, or a new husband was found for
her.
when Godfrey, first Elden Lord, was hounded
from the Lands Between, Radagon left Rennala
to return to the Erdtree Capital, becoming
Queen Marika's second husband and King Consort,
taking the title...of second Elden Lord.
The mystery endures, to this day...
As to why Lord Radagon would cast Lady Rennala
aside... and moreover...why a mere champion
would be chosen for the seat of Elden Lord".
Whatever the case - as a part of this union,
Radagon's prior three children with Rennala
became demi-god step-children (Radahn's Great
Rune), granted grace thanks to their new..family
tree (They became demi-gods just as Godfrey
did, despite not being born into it).
Rennala was broken by this.
And so was her country.
The Queen's Set reads "When Rennala, head
of both the Academy of Raya Lucaria and the
Carian Royal Family, lost her husband Radagon,
her heart went along with him.
And then, those at the academy realized.
That Rennala was no champion, after all".
In the wake of Radagon's betrayal and Rennala's
poor judgement, Liurnia struggled with civil
war - with the Acadamy of Raya Lucaria on
one side, and the Carian Royals on the other.
---
It's at this point - right here ... that Lunar
Princess Ranni, daughter of Rennala and Radagon..stole
a fragment of the Rune of Death.
It happened during the Golden Age of the Erdtree,
long before the shattering of the Elden Ring.
Someone stole a fragment of the Rune of Death
from Maliketh, the Black Blade.
As mentioned previously, Maliketh was Marika's
shadow, and he had sealed away Destined Death
in a black blade.
Once a fragment of the rune of death was stolen
however, Maliketh went a step further.
He bound the blade within his own flesh, such
that none might rob death, ever again (Maliketh's
Black Blade).
It was too late, however.
This fragment of the rune of death was used
immediately - to kill a demi-god.
Marika's own son, Godwyn the Golden.
That was the first recorded Death of a demigod
in all history.
And it became the catalyst.
Soon, the Elden Ring was smashed, and thus
sprang forth the war known as the Shattering.
There is a lot of very credible evidence that
Marika was behind this plot.
There's also a lot of evidence that Marika
is behind the entirety of your Tarnished quest
- but we'll talk about that in another video.
For now, all you need to know is this:
---
After the marriage of Marika and Radagon,
and after the Rune of Death was stolen, Marika
went on to shatter the Elden Ring.
And Radagon attempted to repair it (Marika's
Hammer).
To no avail.
The Elden Ring had been broken into runes
- some great, and some small.
(Note: this was the Law of Causality put into
practice).
Even so, Order remained loosely held together
- for a time.
In fact, I speculate that this is why the
Divine Towers were built.
They're arranged in a ring, and there's one
Divine Tower for each Great Rune of the Elden
Ring (except for the Omen Twins, whose Great
Runes are similar fragments, and Ranni, whose
moon might have taken its benediction).
So that that even after the shattering, order
could be maintained.
But order wasn't the only thing that was getting
forced back together..
You know, it's said that Lord Radagon harboured
a secret...
A famed sculptor of the Erdtree Capital was
once summoned to render Lord Radagon's likeness
in giant stature.
When he glimpsed the skeleton in Radagon's
closet.
And as such, it's said the great statue harbours
his secret too.
Of course, the big twist of Elden Ring.. is
that Radagon IS Marika.
Or, depending on what you believe, he became
her.
For she knew it was going to happen.
(Note: this was the Law of Regression in effect.
All things yearn eternally to converge).
O Radagon, leal hound of the Golden Order.
Thou'rt yet to become me, thou'rt yet to become
a god.
Let us both be shattered, mine other half.
Of all the unknowns in Elden Ring's lore,
this will surely go on to be one of the biggest,
as we move forward.
The wording "thou'rt yet to become me" reinforces
that these were two separate entities before
the shattering.
However, in contrast, there is also evidence
that Radagon was always a part of Marika - for
example, Enia says that all the demi-gods
are the direct offspring of Queen Marika..and
the Mimic Veil reveals that Marika had a propensity
for imitation..so it's even possible that
Radagon was an extension of Marika sent to
seduce Rennala, long ago.
I'll present more concrete theories in the
future, but on this matter, the most important
thing is...what do you think?
The developers really respect your intelligence
and creativity in piecing the story together,
as they've very carefully left certain things
open..and your imagination is a big part of
what makes this story special.
At any rate, the union of Radagon and Marika
seems to be a union of two fundamental opposing
laws of the Golden Order.
Causality, as Marika is an agent of cause
and effect.. and regression, as Radagon is
a character who aspires to be complete in
all things (Radagon Icon).
Fusing them together corrected Marika's deviance,
but even so, she was imprisoned in the Erdtree,
for the shattering.
'Marika's trespass demanded a heavy sentence.
But even in shackles, she remains a god, and
the vision's vessel.'
The Elden Ring had been shattered - though
there was still a period of relative peace
here before the Shattering War began.
In fact, the conjoined Radagon and Marika
even had two demi-god children of their own
during this time: Miquella, and Malenia.
these two children were born afflicted.
Miquella was cursed with eternal childhood,
and Marika harboured a horrific rot within
(Remembrance of the Rot Goddess).
Even so, these two children were both chosen
as Empyreans.
They were immensely sacred (Malenia's Great
Rune), and eligible to inherit godhood from
the Greater Will.
Perhaps the Greater Will was desperate to
find a worthy successor.
Indeed, in the shattering war to come, many
would try to claim the shards of the Elden
Ring, and take the throne.
Including, of course - the Tarnished, returned
from their Long March..at long last -
---
Which we'll talk about in the next main lore
video.
I should probably also mention here that if
you become a patron, you'll see upcoming lore
videos early, as that's one of the rewards
if you pledge to the $3 tier.
And if you really liked this video, then I've
actually also just added a new $20 tier as
well - so that if you think my channel is
worth pledging to for that amount, then you'll
receive a new mug with a unique design every
three months.
There are four to collect - the first is inspired
by dark souls, then Elden Ring, then Sekiro,
and finally Bloodborne - all with fantastic
art that I worked on with an amazing artist
named "choo".
The quality is really nice, and the prints
don't seem to come off at
all in the wash, which is great..not to mention
they're just a good sized mug as well - perfect
for coffee, with a large handle.